the lego ninjago movie is the third in
the now feature film franchise of lego
movies that have consistently surprised
me the first one I had no anticipation
for it was actually really good
same with Lego Batman but Lego Batman is
a character and a world that has so much
richness in it already that Lego could
pull from so much and really appeal to a
wide demographic of people Ninjago
that's a lot more shrunk down to one
core demographic so this is our first
lego movie that is less of a satire and
is more of an action-adventure for
families there are jokes that are a
little boundary-pushing and there's
definitely humor for adults and there's
stuff that kids aren't going to get but
out of the three this is easily so far
the most that's just aimed for families
in general so Lloyd voiced by Dave
Franco is the son of Garmadon this evil
guy who's trying to take over the city
of Ninjago voiced by justin theroux
because he's the son of this evil guy
everyone treats him like crap despite
the fact that he's trying to be a normal
person when in secret
he's the green ninja of the Ninjago clan
and they all fight against Garmadon so
like I said the general feel when it
comes to these lego movies was that most
people thought the first one was just
going to be a terrible product placement
movie and it turned out to be pretty
great and a lot more clever than
everyone thought Lego Batman is part of
a franchise that people respect and like
and you go into that after the first one
expecting something pretty cool to take
the step down from Batman to Ninjago
which is a very popular property and has
a TV show that a lot of people like but
nevertheless you must admit it's nowhere
near as popular as something like that
man people are going to go into this
more judgmental because this is the
first one that looks like okay they
might be out staying there welcome and
that's all thoughts that you can have
going into this movie and that's
dangerous it's always hard to not have
expectations going into a movie but I
tried really hard to not think that way
and I found myself enjoying this movie
is it as good as the previous two no
this is easily the worst of the three as
I said it's nowhere near a satirical or
smart this is more of a straightforward
act
adventure comedy for kids but the
animation is undeniably spectacular the
city of Ninjago is perhaps better
realized than Gotham City was in Lego
Batman it feels like a real breathing
Lego City the voice work as well as some
of the best that I've heard in an
animated film this year particularly
dave franco justin theroux and jackie
chan and i laughed
semi consistently and found myself
enjoying the look of the film however it
at times can get extremely conventional
because it follows a plot that we have
all heard 10,000 times a kid in school
in this case a lego is unpopular in
reality he's doing really cool stuff and
everyone should really like him and he
has a family member who's evil and
they're gonna have to figure out how to
be friends eventually like I mean it's a
plot we've seen ten thousand times over
and I wish the film poked fun at it more
because that's something that the other
Lego movies did particularly the Lego
Batman movie poked fun so much at
Batman's history his backstory this film
didn't do that as much as I wanted
unfortunately it has your basic plot
that we've all seen many times and it
doesn't do much to go beyond that and it
is sort of locked in the confines of
this Ninjago world where it doesn't
really feel like there is that much more
to get into beyond some cool action
sequences and some quippy lines here and
there so it's not as good as the first
two but I still think this is a
perfectly acceptable animation based off
of Lego characters and when you look at
it from that perspective this film is
mostly successful and I really think
that kids are probably going to enjoy
this film and that adults can be okay
with watching it but as I said it's
nowhere near as good as the first two it
is bookended by two live action
sequences featuring the real Jackie Chan
which I thought were really charming I'm
a big fan of his and I like seeing him
do really anything in a movie unless
it's the spy next door
[Music]
can you mommy do that so I think if you
lower your expectations a bit expecting
it to not be as good as the last two
you'll probably think it's okay at best
which is how I felt I'm gonna give the
lego ninjago movie a b- guys thank you
so much as always for watching I just
had a humongous influx of reviews
because there were so many movies that
came out this weekend I wanted to talk
about I really appreciate you guys
watching them also I want to make sure
you guys know that my promotion with
audible is still going on if you guys go
to audible.com slash Chris you can start
your free 30-day trial if you're a
voracious reader like myself but you
don't always have the time to sit down
and read a book and you want to do it on
the go they have an unbeatable selection
of audiobooks with tons of celebrities
and really amazing people who have
provided the narration for these books
if you go to audible.com slash Chris you
can have a free 30-day trial audible
makes getting more books in your life
considerably easier and I appreciate the
fact that they have continued to sponsor
my videos it helps me out quite a bit
and I know it's helped out a lot of you
guys too
thank you very much as always for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get steppen eyes
[Music]